nous avons décidé ce matin d'acter la
fin de la gratuité des tests hors
prescription médicale devrait entrer en
vigueur à la mi octobre c'est conforme à
l'annonce qu'avait faite le président de
la république dans son allocution du 12
juillet c'est aussi conforme pas aux
choix que font un certain nombre de nos
voisins européens en ce moment je veux
rappeler sur ce point que les tests ne
protège pas les tests à répétition
n'empêche pas d'aller à l'hôpital et de
contaminer fortement d'ici mi octobre et
octobre chacun aura eu le temps de
s'organiser et de prendre ses
responsabilités nous prenons également
les nôtres